bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france lyon vient
de le voir présenter comme un vivier de
l'extrême droite depuis une dizaine
d'années quel rôle joue jouerait la
ville dans la diffusion de certaines
idées arnaud benedetti
tu sais pas il ya en effet un certain
nombre de groupes que l'on qualifie de
radicaux qui
existe à lyon depuis un certain nombre
d'années mais plus généralement c'est le
contexte politique aujourd'hui de la
société française qu'il faut prendre en
compte la réalité c'est que les
manifestations dont on a vu cet après
midi qu'elle voulait lutter contre
l'extrême droite sont aussi d'expression
d'une gauche qui a abandonné un certain
nombre de ses fondamentaux notamment la
république et de la nation la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que la bataille
culturelle elle était en partie gagnée
par la droite et ça c'est un
transformations profondes dans la
société française depuis dix ans près de
40 ans les idées dominantes aujourd'hui
sont plutôt des idées dominantes de
droite et cette réalité c'est une vérité
qui pèse fortement sur la vie politique
puisque je crois même le président de la
république issu lui-même du centre
gauche qui n'a cessé de trianguler à
droite durant l'ensemble de son
quinquennat donc je crois que c'est ça
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est un abandon
par une partie de la gauche à la fois
dom22 l'idée même de république de
l'idée même de nation veut également de
la question sociale est sûre c'est en
bas sur ces abandons et sur ses
ambivalences il est aujourd'hui une
bataille culturelle qu'elle était gagné
je le pense par une grande partie de la
droite on entendu eric coquerel de la
france insoumise évoqué une extrême
droite isation du paysage
politico-médiatique aymeric glissa quel
est votre regard vous partager la vie
d'un homme benedetti sur cette sorte
d'appel d'air qui serait provoquée par
une absence
de la gauche dans le débat public
aujourd'hui
je m'inscris davantage dans le propos
d'arnaud benedetti c'est à dire qu'on a
une polarisation la société donc
finalement la gauche extrême gauche is
et finalement on a sauf qu électorale et
une sociologie des grands équilibres en
2001 deux qui sont pas différents des
grands équipes de 2017 vous avez un bloc
de gauche extrême gauche autour de 25%
un bloc social démocrate
et chrétiens démocrates à peu près à 25%
qu'elle bloque du président la
république et finalement à un bloc de
droite plurielle qui fait entre 45 et 50
% des intentions de vote ça c'est la
conséquence d'une victoire culturelle de
la droite il y avait une très bonne
étude de la fondapol qui disait que
finalement l'europe les européens
s'étaient convertis aux valeurs de
droite notamment sur les questions
identitaires sur la sur le libéralisme
économique et sur l'individualisme et la
façon de penser la société donc en fait
c'est finalement une conséquence mais
d'inventer d'eric zemmour c'est
uniquement le prolongement à mon sens du
phénomène qui s'est passé en 2010 à 6 en
finale de dégagisme politique de
recomposition politique on a une
recomposition à gauche autour d'
emmanuel macron est on en train
d'assister à une forme de re composition
politique à droite avec la montée des
risques et nikki ces deux à travers son
diagnostic civilisationnel d'agréger le
parti de l air avec une partie du racing
en national et de recours d'établir une
recomposition des droites sa difficulté
c'est finalement sur le comtat
civilisationnel il arrive à faire cette
union des droites mais actuellement on
aperçoit notamment que le retour des gis
les jeunes de la taille du carburant à
autour des thématiques socio-économique
et là il va devoir réussir à agréger des
personnes aidées électorat qui d'un côté
l'unité pour le retour de la retraite à
60 ans avec marine le pen et de l'autre
côté qui ont voté françois fillon pour
une retraite à 65 le sens exact est donc
là il ya une difficulté dans son dans sa
coalition électorale sur le plan
économique on va on sait pas finalement
si ça va tenir si ça va se consolider et
se traduire en vote finalement à la fin
alors on le rappelle eric zemmour qui
n'est toujours pas officiellement
déclaré candidat et pourtant à moins six
mois de la présidentielle les sondages
se multiplient selon lesquelles marine
le pen eric zemmour accumulerait à eux
deux plus de 30% des intentions de vote
est ce que c'est un score inédit pour
cette partie de la droite aujourd'hui
arnaud bennet étiez ça confirme une
dynamique évidente parce que quand on
regarde toutes les études d'opinion le
nom depuis finalement la rentrée c'est à
dire depuis le mois septembre
on voit que les ce qu'on règle et j'ai
de marine le pen comme vous l'avez dit
d'eric zemmour depuis deux ou trois tous
sens de monsieur du thon taignons sont
que cette famille politique qui est
diverse d'ailleurs avec un certain
nombre de séances et aux alentours de 35
pour ça - jour je rejoins le constat
qu'il y en est c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui finalement le champ
politique est organisée autour d'une
forme de tri pour l'arrêter c'est à dire
une gauche qui est minoritaire qui est
entre 25 et 30% ce qui est laid diaz
historique le plus bas de la gauche
depuis presque 1969 la dernière élection
présidentielle où la gauche n'avait pas
fait plus de 25 concerts avec un parti
communiste qui à l'époque était à 21
cents vous avez ensuite à bloc central
qui est un plan qui n'est pas
majoritaire mais qui est par contre
extrêmement bien organisés
sociologiquement et politiquement c'est
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui manuel macro
reste au malgré tout dans un certain
nombre d'études donc il n'ya pas de plus
a été une nation de vote et un bloc qui
est vraisemblablement majoritaire qui
est le bloc de droite mais un bloc de
droite qui est frappé par il forme de
désunion entre d'un côté les
républicains qui ont du mal à émerger à
faire émerger une candidature
incontestable qui sont compris dans
l'enchevêtrement du congrès à venir et
puis une droite nationale qui est
partagée aujourd'hui entre deux
tendances une tendance qui est plus
civilisationnel en effet qu'il a
tendance que représentait les zemmour
qui finalement occupe l'espace politique
que marine le pen à force de vouloir se
dédiaboliser a d'une certaine manière
laissé à découvert et puis une droite
qui disent on peut être plus populaires
du social que semble exprimer marine le
pen voilà aujourd'hui la filiale à la
laddh me semble-t-il la configuration de
ce 2 champ politique il est clair qu'en
tout cas ce que l'on appelle la droite
nationale n'a jamais été aussi forte à
la veille d'une élection présidentielle
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui leur fin il
faut également prendre avec eux la lan
ou très grande prudence les études
d'opinion parce que on est quand même
encore à six mois c'est un moine chinois
maintenance du premier tour de
l'échéance présidentielle
avant on devait revenir sur cette
thématique des sondages mais avant ça et
brighi c'est marine le pen est installé
dans le paysage politique depuis de
nombreuses années avant qu avant elle à
son père jean-marie le pen on a donc
beaucoup parlé de cette entreprise de
normalisation du parti qu'elle a mené
c'est aussi passer par ce changement non
le front national devenant le
rassemblement national est ce que vous
voyez aimerez ghz et un lien entre cette
évolution du parti du parti le pen et
l'émergence de ce nouveau courant
incarné par eric zemmour
bien sûr le cirque ya eu un phénomène de
recentrage dédiabolisation qu'à libérer
un espace politique à eric zemmour sur
le constat plutôt civilisationnel sur
des combats qui ont été abandonnés par
marie le pen lors de la transition avec
avec son père et finalement on assiste à
la fois à droite à la fois à gauche à un
combat une concurrence pour le
leadership un leadership à droite entre
eric zemmour et marine le pen et le
candidat ait l'air qui sera désigné et
un combat pour le leadership à gauche
avaient commis diverses trendy nature et
ce faisant on a finalement le bloc
central du prénom réduite n'est pas
attaqué et c'est pour ça qu'il réussit à
conserver son son bloc à 25% malgré le
recentrage de marie le pen et la
tendance se déride pluviales suis plutôt
en fait finalement avec des candidatures
plutôt centriste avec larry pécresse
xavier bertrand ou on ne se parlait qui
on tombe sur une tendance mac os
compatible plutôt que sur une tendance
ce plutôt axe droit des républicains on
a finalement un combat pour leadership à
droite un combat pour leadership à
gauche est présent à république qui les
déficits son socle électoral qui est
quasi un touché et qui continue avec son
24 % 20 % dans les intentions de vote
étude après étude en terme d'opinion et
des lectorats arnaud banalité qu'est ce
qui distingue ces deux mouvements marine
le pen eric zemmour
alors si vous voulez la stratégie d'eric
zemmour c'est une stratégie qui vise il
le dit d'ailleurs un
réconcilier disons la droite
conservatrice bourgeoise et les classes
populaires pour l'instant on voit que
quand même la dynamique des six lots
c'est une dynamique qui a pris
essentiellement
disons au sein même de l'électorat du
rassemblement national puisque marie le
pen a perdu clé de 10 points en quelques
en quelques semaines mais que qu'il
arrive aussi à prendre une partie de
l'électorat filloniste de 2017 les
études notamment celle de louis harris
se montre que disons dans cette zone de
chalandise électorale il prendrait entre
25 et 30% de l'électorat fillonniste de
2017 il y avait vraisemblablement chez
zemmour une composante sociologique est
un peu différente que celle de de marine
le pen est le véritable enjeu pour
l'élection de 2022 et le finalement qui
sera au coeur me semble-t-il de la
campagne c'est de reconquérir
l'électorat populaire c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron tire sa
force du désinvestissement
citoyen et civique ou électorale peu
importe comment l'appel des classes
populaires et d'une partie des classes
moyennes si les classes populaires et
les classes moyennes retourne dans les
bureaux de vote la configuration
politique à venir pourrait en être
changée et la bataille que doit
aujourd'hui mener en effet une partie de
la droite quelle qu'elle soit c'est de
ramener à elle ses classes populaires
qui ne se retrouvent plus dans l'offre
politique de gauche parce que la gauche
a abandonné maintenant depuis une
vingtaine d'années des classes
populaires d'autres clientèles
électorales comment est ce que vous
voyez la réaction est vrai glissait de
marine le pen face à l'émergence de ce
qu'on appelle bien souvent le phénomène
eric zemmour est ce qu'elle a du souci à
se faire et qui est quand même installé
dans ce champ politique depuis bien plus
longtemps
elle est confrontée à un problème qui
est assez complexe le premier puis on a
pu voir le changement de stratégie en
fonction du potentiel électoral des dix
mois au début avec tout net recul qui
étaient bienveillants vis-à-vis d'eric
zemmour puisque finalement c'était une
base des toiles qui est à peu près
similaire et puis les rythmes on ne
remet tait pas en cause sa potentielle
qualification au second tour et depuis
que eric zemmour de potentiellement
remettre en cause sa qualification au
second tour ce qu'il est dit depuis les
études d'opinion ça faisait plus de cinq
ans que marine le pen était quasiment
systématiquement aux se qualifier au
second tour on a eu un changement de
discours évidemment il fallait attaquer
eric zemmour sur ses propos vis-à-vis
des femmes sur son programme sur son
constat est pour finalement réussir à
reprendre le leadership sur la droite
mais ce faisant elle réduit aussi ses
chances au second tour d'avoir un report
de voix favorables de la part des
acteurs d'un examen au cercle là le
grand problème du de marine le pen on
l'a vu en 2017 c'est l'incapacité à
créer une dynamique au second tour alors
que finalement l'essentiel de ses
réserves de voix sont exprimés au
premier tour et pour gagner de second
tour il faut avoir plus de voix que
l'adversaire est donc de réussir à avoir
une coalition qui sait une coalition à
l'étoile qu'il soit plus large pour
qu'on ait tour à créer une dynamique
pour gagner au second tour donc à douala
fois réussir à se maintenir devant eric
zemmour est donc à l'attaqué sur ses
propres thèmes pour pas eu les c
l'hégémonie ce de ces thèmes sur
l'immigration sur l'insécurité et en
même temps ne pas frustrer
l'électoralisme puisqu'il elle en aura
besoin si elle qualifié au second tour
pour imprimer une dynamique et être en
capacité ou pas de concurrencer le
présent la république au second tour non
mais détient on parle beaucoup et on se
base aujourd'hui sur des intentions de
vote c'est ce qu'il ne faut pas se
méfier roman s'interroger sur le rôle
des sondages aujourd'hui c'est quoi
c'est un instrument de mesure ou bien ça
participe réellement de la création de
l'opinion et donc de certains phénomènes
ça participe des deux c'est à dire qu'on
est chez
un sondage c'est un état des rapports de
force un instant donné sachant que dans
une élection présidentielle la
cristallisation comme on dit des
rapports de force elle s'effectue dans
les dernières semaines c'est tout ça
qu'aujourd'hui il est encore trop tôt
pour tirer des enseignements qui sont à
claire et définitive sur ce qui va se
passer dans quelques mois mais en même
temps on mixe un impact sur le jeu
politique les sondages participe aussi
d'une certaine manière autant qu'ils
font tous la philo millions à construire
l'opinion publique et surtout à impacter
les rapports de force politiques entre
les différentes forces politiques donc
les sondages ont un effet en effet
direct sur le jeu politique mais
également sur la sédimentation des
opinions publiques sachant quand même et
ça il faut le rappeler mais moi je le
dis à chaque fois c'est que si l'on
prend l'histoire politique histoire des
élections présidentielles depuis
maintenant quasiment cinq ou six
élections présidentielles crois que
finalement les intentions ventes qu'ils
étaient photographiés à six mois de
l'élection présidentielle ont
pratiquement toutes été infirmée par la
réalité ensuite du du scrutin tel qu'il
s'est déroulé le jour j c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être très prudents d'autant
plus que ce qui s'exprime aujourd'hui
dans les intentions de vote sont ceux
qui ont le rapport le plus intense à
politiques ceux qui sont les plus
intéressés par la politique et donc en
effet il y à un certain nombre de
catégories qui vont s'intéresser
beaucoup plus tard à cette élection et
dont il faudra bien prendre en compte
ensuite bien évidemment l'orientation
électorale merci à tous les deux
messieurs d'avoir participé à cet
échange ce soir arnaud benedetti un
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire et aimerait glissait
secrétaire général adjoint du think tank
le millénaire